it's been revealed today that the
government's green homes grant scheme
cost a thousand pounds for each
household that took part just an
administration now the initiative was
scrapped in march after facing problems
with delivery but making our homes more
climate friendly is going to be key if
the uk is going to meet its climate
target so how can we make our homes
greener and who should pay for it chilly
to you first of all it was a pretty
damning assessment by the national audit
office about the green homes grant so
looking to the future how do we go about
making our homes more energy efficient
well what we need is a properly
administered government program so that
we get a just transitional process there
are no routes out of energy poverty that
don't include renewable energy so when
when the national audit office says that
the 12-week timetable that the hm
treasury department set for this entire
program for 600 000 homes in the middle
of covet last year when they say it was
over ambitious the national audit office
were actually being incredibly
diplomatic what basically happened was a
really good very important scheme that
would they've delivered you know
hundreds of thousands of jobs and saved
hundreds of
thousands of tons of co2 fell apart
because the way it was administered and
the period during which it was
administered just didn't allow it to be
effective
we need to do what the ippr suggests
which is go back
focus on local delivery focus on local
people focus on job creation and carry
out the the green homes grant that 62
percent of the public were about to
apply for until it was cut prematurely
okay stephanie i just wanted to to
explain why we're talking about this why
it's important because there is a
statistic here from the national uh
housing federation that shows that
england's homes produce more carbon
emissions every year than all of the
country's cars which is an extraordinary
stat isn't it but it's expensive isn't
it i mean if you're going to insulate
people's home put double glazing in
you're going to take out people's gas
boilers it all costs money so who pays
for that is it the individuals do we pay
through the tax system how should we pay
i mean you raise the really important
points and the reason this is all being
discussed is there's actually a vacuum
at the moment whereby you know we're
waiting for a heat and building strategy
to come from the uk government uh we
were anticipating that before the summer
it's uh it's now looking like it's
coming uh in before october and that is
um you know critical and not only in
setting a date for phasing out uh gas
borders but but also actually setting
out some policies that can actually help
support people
you